le froid paralyse la moitié nord de la
france pas d'amélioration pour demain au
nord de la seine les 11 otages de chypre
les terroristes accepterait de les
libérer si on les laisse repartir dans
un pays d'europe de l'est comment
répondre aux goûts des enfants pour la
musique c'était le thème des premières
assises nationales de la musique
invité du journal jean d'écriennes
ancien aide de camp du général de gaulle
pour son livre de gaulle de loin et de
près et nous parlerons aussi musique à
la fin de cette édition madame
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir les
habitants du nord de la france viennent
de connaître peut-être le week-end le
plus dur de l'hiver tempête de neige
froid très vif verglas trois éléments
qui ont pratiquement bloqué durant 24
heures toute vie à l'extérieur des
maisons
la région la plus touchée c'est
peut-être le département de la manche
avec des centaines de poteaux
électriques qui se sont effondrés sous
le poids de la glace des centaines
d'arbres qui se sont abattues coupant
les routes et les voies de communication
les comics des conditions atmosphériques
qui je vous le disais ont bloqué et
toute activité dans le nord du pays et
jusque dans paris l'aéroport de roissy
en france par exemple à quelques
kilomètres de la capitale a dû être
fermée les décollages n'ont repris que
vers 14 heures d'ordinaire à paris la
neige ne tient pas la circulation
urbaine a vite fait de la transformer en
soupe
et dès le matin la ville se retrouve
crottés jusqu'aux genoux mais
aujourd'hui c'était dimanche et les
parisiens sont restés chez eux
bien leur en a pris car sur la moitié
nord du pays les routes étaient
glissantes ou impraticables notamment en
normandie où plusieurs centaines de
voitures ont été immobilisées par des
congères
la neige est tombée sidru dans cette
région qu'elle a même gâché nui no
saiper des jeunes mariés sont restés
bloqués toute la nuit dans la salle des
fêtes avec la noce jusqu'à l'arrivée des
pompiers
cette fois encore la neige et le froid
ont fait des victimes dans la somme un
vieillard saisie par le froid sur sa
terrasse et dans le gard une jeune femme
surprise par la neige et dont le corps a
été retrouvé à quelques centaines de
mètres
d'une ferme à roissy l'aéroport charles
de gaulle a été fermé toute la matinée
au trafic est rien pour permettre aux
chasse neige de dégager les pistes et de
nombreux retards ont encore été
enregistrés dans l'après midi
quant au tiercé il a lui-même subi les
conséquences du mauvais temps ce devait
être le premier tiercé de réouverture
d'auteuil
mais la piste était impraticable
la réunion a donc été reportée sur
vincennes où les trotteurs ont dû
remplacer au sabot lever les sauteurs
l'arrivée s'est déroulée dans de talent
gerbe debout il a presque fallu essuyer
les plaques des chevaux pour savoir que
le cese boni dio avait gagné devant sur
huit lots panne et le 1 ab aux 16 18 as
donc pour le tiercé de vincennes
dans le secteur du xvième
arrondissements touchés vendredi par une
série d'explosions de gaz la neige dans
les rues reste est immaculé tout au long
de cette journée il est vrai que ce
quartier de paris et de joie interdite à
toute circulation aussi bien en voiture
qu'à pied personne ne peut franchir les
cordons de police il s'agit d'éviter de
nouveaux accidents et aussi d'empêcher
le pillage des centaines d'appartements
désertées par leurs habitants en déserté
en catastrophe vendredi après midi ses
habitants auront d'ailleurs
progressivement revenir dans leur
appartement à partir de demain à 14
heures
mais ils n'auront ni eau ni gaz ni
électricité le dc-8 chypriote qui a
décollé hier de chypre avec 11 otages
quatre membres d'équipage et deux
pirates de l'air palestinien est revenu
en fin d'après midi sur l'aéroport de
nicosie après avoir fait une escale de
plusieurs heures à djibouti nous voulons
d'ailleurs de recevoir les premières
images de ce détournement et de ce cette
prise d'otages dans l'île de chypre à
nicosie lors d'une réunion du comité de
solidarité des pays afro et asiatiques
des images que nous allons voir
vraisemblement dans une seconde et qui
nous parviennent depuis quelques minutes
en direct de djibouti et du caire hier
soir sur l'aéroport de larnaca ce cas
revient année les 11 otages les deux
terroristes à ceux dé 6,8 qui après un
aller-retour par djibouti s'est de
nouveau posé ce soir à chypre
c'est ici dans l'hôtel hilton de nicosie
qu'a eu lieu la prise d'otage par deux
hommes armés qui ont aussitôt abattu
youssef al sebaï n anciens ministres
égyptiens mais surtout l'un des amis les
plus proches du président sadate
regardez ces images saisissantes et au
talent sorte les mains liées avec leurs
propres cravate sous les armes des
terroristes
cet homme l'un des otages chypriote
libérés immédiatement a indiqué que les
des terroristes avait délibérément
rabattu monsieur sebaï dont les obsèques
justement avait lieu au caire ce matin
cette action l'organisation d'abou nidal
réfugiés en irak pourrait compter dans
leurs rangs les instigateurs de ce
meurtre politique
ce sont ces organisations ne l'oublions
pas qui ont condamné à mort ses
étudiants qui ont accompagné sadate à
jérusalem mois de novembre
en tant que journaliste et ami du
président sadate l'un d'eux delà de la
personne du cp se bat et donc c'est
toute l'egypte de sadate qui se sent
visé était prêt à serrer les rangs
derrière son prêt dit en mouvement les
négociations avec israël sont dans
l'impasse c'est dans ce sens que le
réflexe de terreur escompté à jouer et
on peut valablement penser que l'équipe
qui vous n'appelez enterré aujourd'hui
avec youssef ce bail grande partie des
dernières illusions qu'elle nourrissait
l'égard de ses frères palestiniens
le dénouement de la prise d'otages sur
l'aéroport de nicosie gouailleur
déterminera sans doute les conditions
dans lesquelles le gouvernement du caire
que le monde arabe attend de voir
et puis avec l'autre des informations de
dernière minute viennent de nous
parvenir sur ce détournement d'avion oui
effectivement l'instant on apprend que
des combats se déroulerait sur
l'aérodrome de larnaca à chypre donc
l'aérodrome où se trouve le dc-8 dans
lequel les pirates de l'air retiennent
les otages c'est là le service d'écouté
de la télévision israélienne qui
rapporte ça on pense que c'est un
commando égyptien qui a attaqué l'avion
afin de libérer les otages dans un peu
moins de quatre heures
la campagne officielle pour les
élections
initiative des 12 et 19 mars prochain
sera ouverte cela signifie que s'il a
envie que vous en prend il ne vous reste
plus qu'un peu moins de quatre heures
pour vous porter candidat vous ne serez
pas le seul sachez par exemple qu'à
paris pour l'instant tu 300 personnes se
sont déjà proposés qui nous représenter
à l'assemblée nationale la campagne
officielle cela signifie surtout qu'au
niveau des circonscriptions
les candidats vont pouvoir déployer tout
l'arsenal mis au point par les
spécialistes parce que l'on appelle le
marketing politique
la campagne officielle à la radio et à
la télévision commencera elle le 27
février c'est à dire lundi en 8e
aujourd'hui c'était un peu un week-end
de repos avant le grand sprint final au
fait de ce sprint les forces en présence
savent d'ailleurs maintenant à peu près
à quoi s'en tenir le dernier sondage de
l'express vous pourrez le découvrir
demain dans les kiosques annonce que la
gauche serait crédité actuellement de
51% des voix contre 45% à la majorité
d'un copain en voyant ces chiffres et en
les comparant peut-être ou par exemple à
ceux des mois de septembre d'octobre ou
de novembre
on a un peu l'impression que la pré
campagne électorale qui était fort
longue mais finalement pas changé
l'opinion des électeurs français louis
les six derniers mois ont été marqués
par des événements politiques importants
aussi bien dans la majorité que dans
l'opposition on a l'impression que tout
contraire tout se passe un peu comme si
les jeux étaient faits déjà depuis
longtemps depuis plusieurs mois en tout
cas trois semaines de campagne
officielle peuvent-ils peuvent elles
changer les choses bien on le verra mais
au moment où sur cette campagne
officielle je crois que ce que l'on peut
constater ce que la france n'est pas
seulement comme on l'a dit longtemps
divisé politiquement en deux mais
qu'elle est également partagée en quatre
et à la question principale qui
l'emportera à la majorité ou
l'opposition
il faut ajouter tout de suite une
seconde question qui n'est pas
nécessairement d'ailleurs secondaire
quels seront les rapports de force à
l'intérieur de chacun des deux camps bon
alors comment s'en vend ces deux
courants la majorité de leurs liens dans
la majorité de la situation c'est dans
une certaine mesure clarifier avec la
création récente de l'union pour la
démocratie française qui regroupe les
radicaux les centristes du cds et le
parti républicain un regroupement qui
par son nom et par ses affiches
nous avons montré une fiche guerre lors
de l'interview de monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber à 13h01 à un
regroupement d'ong qui se réclame très
directement du président de la
république
mais cette simplification aviv aussi la
concurrence et c'est ainsi
qu'aujourd'hui une déclaration de
monsieur
chirac accuse les partenaires de
monsieur chirac d'avoir remis en cause
en créant cette udf les accord qui a été
négocié tout au long de l'été et de
l'automne dernier du côté de
l'opposition mais du côté de
l'opposition la coupure est encore plus
net les positions sont plus tranchés il
n'y a pas d'accord politique et on ne
voit pas comment il pourrait y en avoir
un avant de toute façon le premier tour
quand l accord électoral le parti
socialiste lui a décidé déjà depuis un
certain temps le désistement pour les
communistes au second tour lorsque les
communistes serait devant ses propres
candidats
les communistes eux attendent pour se
prononcer le résultat du premier tour et
c'est là répétons le une fois de plus la
principale inconnue de ce scrutin
puisque d'après les sondages que vous
citiez tout à l'air il semble bien que
la gauche gagnera gagnerait ou perdrait
elle selon qu'elle abordera le premier
tour en étant unis ou au contraire on
affronte ainsi noël
le chapitre des déclarations politiques
de cette journée on note aussi les
propos tenus ce soir il ya quelques
minutes seulement au club de la presse
par monsieur françois ceyrac pour le
président du patronat français
si l'opposition l'emportent nous aurons
des grèves et de sérieuses difficultés
sociales chaque fois que la gauche l'a
emporté a déclaré françois ceyrac des
grèves et des mouvements sociaux ont
marqué ce succès pour ouvrir le feu de
la campagne officielle antenne 2 vous
donne d'ailleurs un rendez-vous georges
marchais le secrétaire général du parti
communiste français sera opposé demain
soir à 20h30 sur antenne 2 chez nous
donc à monsieur alain peyrefitte le
garde des sceaux un choc attendu
peut-être le plus grand affrontement de
la campagne électorale un débat à 20h30
demain sur antenne 2 organisé à la fois
par notre chaîne et aussi par europe
numéro un et qui sera dirigée par jean
pierre elkabbach et etienne mougeotte et
puis dans ce débat électoral un livre a
fait une apparition un livre d'histoire
certes mais d'une histoire tellement
contemporaine qu'elle peut peut-être
donner des arguments aux seins ou bien
aux le colonel décrit elle vient
d'écrire de gaulle de loin ou de près un
livre qui est publié chez plon est l'une
des révélations de cet ouvrage concerne
les relations qu'ils avaient le général
de gaulle et monsieur georges pompidou à
partir de ce que l'on a appelé la
déclaration de rome c'était le 17
janvier 1969 monsieur georges pompidou
venait d'annoncer son intention de se
porter le moment venu candidat à la
présidence de la république
o'connell merci d'être venus ce soir
selon vous pour le général de gaulle
cette déclaration a été l'un des
éléments de l'échec du référendum sur
les régions et sur le sénat est donc là
des éléments du départ général de gaulle
du pouvoir vous savez quand on voit
effectivement les le faible pourcentage
des non au référendum d'avril 69
on pense effectivement qu'il a suffit de
très peu de choses pour faire pencher la
balance du côté des noms et aux yeux du
général il est certain que
c'était là la déclaration de rome
l'attitude de georges pompidou a été un
des éléments
ça n'a pas été seul certainement celle
qui est pas lui qui l emportait m'enfin
ça a été un des éléments c'est sûr aux
yeux du général général refuse aussi
l'idée que ce sont des journalistes qui
ont tendu un piège monsieur profit du
rhum et qu'en réalité la déclaration de
rome et bien l'ancien premier ministre
du général naveh mûrement réfléchi il
avait mûrement pensée c'est exact le
général pense que georges pompidou et
une même connaissait suffisamment les
journalistes pour ne pas tomber dans un
piège de leurs pas et vous croyez que il
lui en a voulu vraiment terriblement
partir de ce moment là difficile à dire
disons que il a trouvé que l'attitude
n'avait pas été ce qu'elles auraient ce
qui attend dès lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 69 qui a donc suivi le
départ du général de gaulle du pouvoir
le général vous aurait dit qu'il
n'aurait eu qu'à un mot à dire pour que
georges pompidou ne soit pas élu
est ce qu'à votre avis il a eu envie un
moment ou un autre de dire ce mieux
certainement pas il s'est dégradé sur ce
domaine on est khaled est parfaitement
conscient qu effectivement et à l'époque
où se trouvait en présence et georges
pompidou et monsieur power c'est à dire
au second tour et il est certain que si
à ce moment là il avait
fait un communiqué s'il avait dit à un
mot en disant que georges pompidou ne
t'ai pas son candidat qu'ils ne
soutenaient pas qu'il ne pourrait pas su
que candidat tueur il est certain je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de
l'ambiance de l'époque si vous souvenez
des pourcentages
il est absolument sûr que ces pauvres
hères qui aurait été du moins je le
crois je pense que beaucoup de gens
partagent cette opinion mais le général
l'a constaté c'est vrai mais il lui est
pas venue du tout à l'idée de dire ce
mot car le général comme il le dit
d'ailleurs je leur apporte dans ce livre
a toujours été ennemis de la politique
du pire
pas question pour lui de faire la
politique du pire il faut c'était un
grand pragmatique le général alors
compte tenu de la situation compte tenu
des éléments compte tenu des sommes à il
s'agit de faire ce qui doit être fait
pour éviter le pire voilà c'est tout
mais mon colonel
en publiant ce livre vous pénétrez un
peu dans le monde de la politique
actuelle vous pénétrez dans le monde
électorale le rpr par exemple
antigaulliste actuelles évoquent souvent
la filiation directe qu'il est qui
existe entre le général de gaulle
monsieur georges pompidou et le les
gaullistes actuellement alors vous
réfuté cette thèse vous croyez que je
garde le vol aurait réfuté cette thèse
de la filiation directe entre lui et je
me suis alors là j'en sais rien vous
savez j'ai souvent dit que
il ne fallait pas faire parler le
général de gaulle après sa mort et dire
ce que pourrait dire ce que pourrait
penser le général de gaulle aujourd'hui
à propos de tel ou tel problème sur
telle ou telle question est-ce que untel
est bien l'héritier d'un tel vous
comprenez là je n'ai pas le droit de
dire ce que j'en pense parce que je ne
sais pas ce qu'il faut en penser
je crois que le général et aurait
certainement eu une opinion mais
pour vous dire exactement ce qu'il
aurait dit ce qu'il aurait fait je n'en
sais rien et il ne faut pas à faire
parler tout le temps le général en
disant il aurait fait ceci il aurait
fait cela on s'est peut-être en gros
souvent ce qu'il n'aurait pas fait non
c'est penser qu'il aurait fait vous avez
été longtemps l'aide de camp du général
de gaulle vous avez démissionné de
l'armée maintenant vous êtes renom et
une civile si le démon de la politique
que vous prenez aujourd'hui dans quel
parti politique
iriez vous inspire pour écouter j'irai
là où j'ai des amis c'est exact et
j'avoue que j'ai un certain nombre
d'amis au rpr
j'en ai aussi ailleurs c'est vrai enfin
j'ai des amis ou rpr c'est exact merci
beaucoup mon club je rappelle le titre
de votre ouvrage de gaulle de loi et de
presse publié chez plon un ouvrage du
colonel jean d'écriennes l'ancien à
l'aide de cordes général de gaulle dans
cette campagne électorale ans et on
parle aussi beaucoup du smic sur notre
antenne hier soir monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber déclarait que le smic à
2400 francs ce devait être l'objectif du
gouvernement
une déclaration qui a suscité
l'étonnement aujourd'hui de monsieur
jacques chirac alors le smic qu'est ce
que c'est et bien en clair c'est le
salaire minimum qui peut être versé à un
travailleur par une entreprise sept à
huit cent mille français actuellement
son pays à ce salaire minimum
c'est-à-dire 1750 francs par mois pour
cent soixante treize heures de travail
comment peut-on vivre en gagnant aussi
peu d'argent comment peut-on se nourrir
se vêtir se distraire aussi c'est ce que
nous allemands ont voulu savoir sans
nous occuper de statistiques ou bien de
moyenne en regardant simplement vivre
des smicards
jean caron 30 ans ouvrier dans une usine
de produits alimentaires marié père de
quatre enfants
son usine est à 15 kilomètres du village
où il habite
mais il n'ya ni autobus ni cars de
ramassage alors il faut avoir une
voiture l'écart on possède une très
vieille précieuse parce qu indispensable
jean et smicards il gagne 1800 francs
par mois auxquels viennent s'ajouter
mille francs d'allocation logement et
d'allocations du salaire unique
ces mille francs disparaissent dans les
frais fixes location de la maison
électricité essence assurance reste le
salaire de jean 1800 francs pour faire
vivre pendant un mois une famille de six
personnes
les fins de mois sont souvent difficiles
il faut calculer à jongler s'appelle
google
alors on renie un peu surtout en premier
lieu sur l'habillement
j'ai sur le marché beaucoup en solde je
suis d'un grand magasin et puis je mets
belle-soeur qui m'en donne géré partager
mes trois enfants et trois filles âgés
de la sonde a trois filles j'ai passé
une après l'autre l'acte garçon vraiment
que c'est aujourd'hui d'acheter comme ça
et pour nous avons marié oise est pareil
marché un grand magasin
pour nous les drômois les magasins avec
tiko bouchehr comme nous prenons là
quand même comme un chapeau l'entretenir
beaucoup envie qu'on me dise il est
commode je fais tout pour être plus bas
possible on rogne aussi sur la
nourriture 60 francs par jour pour
nourrir deux adultes deux enfants qui
mangent comme des adultes et deux petits
c'est très peu j'aurais son talent ne
peuvent pas faire de folies au
supermarché il examine soigneusement les
étiquettes et achètent systématiquement
les articles en promotions beaucoup
d'interdits aussi ce jour là par exemple
les gens me chantal sens assez faut
s'arrêter devant les légumes et les
fruits pour le plus souvent nous allons
d'helaba le port et contre tout une fois
par semaine les enfants n'ont résisté
longtemps
le match est moins cher le veau dans
n'importe quelle forme tant notre côte
sans prise parce que vraiment c'est
rossi et légumes on prend les pâtes les
pommes de terre
je prends des légumes secs terre cuite
quoi et puis pour le soir souvent on
mange on a commandé reste du midi donc
l'histoire et la volaille
on a même construit j'avance je crois
car moi et les yeux on a ainsi le sais
c'est pas trop cher c'est tout le monde
est tout simple vous avez des rêves vous
rêvez de faire quelque chose que je ne
pourrais jamais faire beaucoup
non qu'est ce que vous disent que vous
voudriez leurs vacances à la montagne et
vos futures est ce que vous auriez cet
enfant ça fasse des études ou bien si le
problème sinon c'est important
actuellement ils vont à l'école primaire
la langue guillemets dans trois ans la
première valait certainement hausser le
geab landry à quelques kilomètres et ça
va causer aucun problème parce que sa
venue dimanche et ensuite quel garçon
qui va suivre
michel ça tout ça va dépendre de leurs
capacités intellectuelles en fin de
compte enfin ils sont amoureux qui
suivent leurs études alors ce serait
malheureux de priver des enfants qui ont
peut-être à niveau pour poursuivre des
études parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
financiers
en fait vous voudriez pas qu'ils
connaissent que vous connaissez c'est
sûr c'est très sûr et il faut qu'on
trouve le système justement pour ça
qu'on est un peu ça vous pose des
problèmes ne meurt de ne pas pouvoir
leur permettre peut-être un jour de
suivre des études normales on a quand
même été curé de voir les autres avoir
cru cuit heures bon bah on vit dans la
limite minimum une information de
dernière minute qui viennent de nous
parvenir une information extrêmement
surprenante elle nous vient de chypre où
il se passe des choses extrêmement
bizarre je me permets de le dire sur
l'aéroport de larnaca où se trouve
l'avion des linières une chypriote qui
était détourné avec lots de pêche
confirme qu'une fusillade a bien éclaté
sur l'aéroport de larnaca
alors selon cette dépêche une centaine
d'hommes seraient sortis de l'avion
militaire égyptien un avion militaire
qui stationnait depuis hier soir sur
l'aéroport et ses commandos aurait tiré
à l'armé lourde sur les bâtiments de
l'aéroport il y aurait déjà plusieurs
tués et plusieurs avions détruits on n'a
pas de plus de précisions nous n'aurons
dans la soirée je pense oui peut-être
même avant la fin de ce journal en tous
les cas nous vous donnerons les
dernières informations dès que nous les
aurons
les membres du conseil de l'information
sur l'énergie électro-nucléaire sont
connus depuis ce matin ils sont 18 et
leur mission est de veiller à ce que le
public est accès à l'information à
propos de l'énergie électro-nucléaire
sans que la notion de secret militaire
ou de secret industriel soit opposé à
toute demande de renseignement dans ce
conseil qui présidé par madame simone
veil ne trouveront des noms très connus
comme le professeur jean-bernard par
exemple ou bien monsieur philippe saint
marc où robert l'a testé nous trouvons
aussi les noms de deux journalistes que
vous connaissez bien
françois de closets le chronique
scientifique de nos confrères de tf1 et
louis blériot le rédacteur en chef
d'antenne
on ne s'arrêtait pas encore aperçus mais
la télévision finalement a servi de
révélateur
en diffusant bon nombre d'opéras les
français sont sinon tous musiciens ils
sont être nombreux à être mélomane la
preuve en est d'ailleurs dans les
chiffres il y a quinze ans la france
comptait 50 conservatoire de musique il
y en a 700 aujourd'hui une explosion
donc musicale une explosion musicale qui
pose tout de même certains problèmes
pour essayer de les résoudre une
douzaine d'associations et aussi des
syndicats d'enseignants se sont donc
retrouvés aujourd'hui à paris il
s'agissait des premières assises
nationales d'un
seulement musicale en france des
professeurs des parents des directeurs
de conservatoire planche depuis deux
jours car leurs élèves ou leurs enfants
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreux à
vouloir apprendre la musique
l'enseignement musical doit donc estimé
responsable passer à un stade supérieur
de développement ce qui pose deux
problèmes un problème financier bien sûr
car les conservatoires ne dépendent que
des municipalités
notre problème actuel c'est la poursuite
de ce qui a été entrepris
nous devons absolument trouver un second
souffle d'enseignement musical qu'il y a
du succès on a réveillé si j'ose dire
d'abord la belle au bois dormant et
cherche un second souffle donc il va
d'abord être financier puisque
actuellement les subventions de l'état
sont de l'ordre de 6 à 10% 12% meilleur
des cas nous notre but c'est d'obtenir
une participation de l'état à 33% aux
établissements contrôlés
deuxième point à l'ordre du jour un
problème de structure
on a enseignement musical actuellement
est répartie entre divers ministères qui
ont des responsabilités chacune dans des
domaines particuliers en particulier
éducation nationale et culture
nous souhaitons une collaboration
d'abord très étroite entre ces
différents ministères et d'autre part
une coordination dans la direction et on
peut on peut dire que ce pays pauvre
musicalement s'offre une anarchie
directionnelle luxueuse et coûteuse
contre eux si nous voulons lutter en
demandant par en particulier peut-être
une grande direction de l'enseignement
musical
enfin reste l'éternel problème toujours
mal résolu en france de l'enseignement à
l'école qui devrait être le lieu
privilégié de sensibilisation à la plus
grande échelle s'il existe au niveau des
maternelles une formation efficace s'il
existe certains professeurs dans les
collèges et malheureusement pas dans
tous il n'existe en tout cas rien au
niveau de l'école élémentaire et ça a
été la première demande que nous ayons
formulé hier
deux propositions enfin que tous les
collèges possèdent au moins une chorale
et si possible des instruments
l'enseignement actuel étant souvent un
grain bien nous restait à connaître
l'avis des principaux intéressés pour
l'enseignement musical en france c'est à
dire les élèves avec une lan à un jeune
musicien fabrice parigaux tu en sors je
crois et tu vis avec un étui de violon
tu étudies violent depuis longtemps
depuis trois ans conservatoire et depuis
cinq ans j'aime la musique ce sont des
parents qui l'ont obligée à faire la
musique ou c'est toi qui a choisi ton
instrument non c'est j'avais vu un
concert fait par des roumains à la
campagne et j'ai eu envie de faire du
bien c'est le coup de foudre tout d'un
coup oui c'est facile de violence ou
trois courses très difficiles à jouer
comme tous les instruments tu fais la
musique aussi à l'école oui je fais la
musique leur parle par semaine alors
comment cela se passe-t-il les
professeurs de musique sont ils toujours
aussi mal traités qu'il ya quelques
années par leurs élèves
est-ce que c'est court mais je considère
vraiment comme une discipline mineure on
s'en moque un peu c'est comme la
gymnastique en seraient exemptés quand
on n'a pas envie il ya les professions
ne sont pas écoutés j'écoute est ce
qu'on fait dans une classe de musique à
l'école on joue du pipeau toujours du
pipeau
ça fait ch on fait du seul flash et bien
tu préfère jouer jouer au conservatoire
ou bien faire ta petite heure de musique
à l'école comme ça conservateur c'est
sérieux c'est plus sérieux c'est plus
dur aussi
est ce que tu veux faire plus tard tu es
de musiciens professionnels ou bien tu
veux que ça reste pour toi un
passe-temps une détente militantes ou
profonds sont s'est pas encore n'ont pas
choisi la profession comme bien merci en
tout cas devenue fabrice ce soir on va
entendre un tout et je dirais pas un
petit camarade puisqu'il est plus âgé de
tous et nous allons l'entendre tout à
l'heure le tiercé
je voudrais vous en parler rapidement
vous connaissez déjà la combinaison
gagnante le 16 le 18 hélas nous avons
nous venons de recevoir les rapports
alors pour le 16 le 18 hélas dans
l'ordre 6005 francs 50 pour 5 francs
bien sûr et dans un ordre différent
1000e 42 francs 50 toujours pour 5
francs et toujours pour le 16 le 18
hélas nous parlions du mauvais temps en
commençant ce journal je vous propose de
le refermer par le même sujet la météo
que nous promet en effet pour demain à
temps froid pluvieux et neigeux sur la
haute-normandie les flandres l'alsace la
lorraine et les vosges de la bretagne à
la normandie au bassin parisien et au
nord des alpes le temps sera plus doux
mais plus vieux et sur le reste du pays
une nette amélioration est à attendre le
soleil fera par exemple sa réapparition
très fréquemment sur l'aquitaine au sud
des alpes et sur la corse ce redoux aura
tout de même une contrepartie on
s'attend à des avalanches nombreux en
montagne et à des inondations un tout
petit peu partout dans les bassins
français voilà cette édition est
maintenant terminée peu après 22h30
c'était avec l'eau qui vous donnera les
dernières informations de cette journée
mais pour nous quitter en vous
souhaitant une bonne soirée j'ai demandé
à michel moraguès à un élève de jean
pierre rapallo conservatoire national
supérieur de musique de paris de nous
faire une petite démonstration de la
qualité d'enseignement musical en france
c'est donc avec le premier mouvement de
la sonate pour flûte de jean sébastien
bach que je vous dis bonsoir
à